restaurant week is another way that you
can help the food bank
a portion of what you spend goes to
three square and also to the restaurant
to help them get through this pandemic
it's been so hard for them
hector mejia live this morning in the
downtown arts district showing off some
specials over at main street provisions
hector some beautiful dishes in front of
you there
oh that is so true they make some great
food here check this out we're really
having
fine dining at four five six o'clock in
the morning i mean this
is just this is the way to start the
morning and joining us live we have
michelle here with three square to talk
to us
not just about our restaurants extending
their menu for restaurant week but also
we're down to the last days yeah we are
restaurant week goes through the 18th
and it's great that we have several
restaurants that have extended and are
going through the 25th this month so
pretty awesome after the height of the
pandemic can you tell us why is it so
crucial for us to keep
rallying together and support the
community and give back
one in six people in southern nevada are
food insecure
one in four kids in southern nevada
lives in a food insecure home
so there are a lot of people that need
help and like you said right after the
pandemic
so many people found themselves
unemployed kids out of school
lots of different circumstances that all
of a sudden me finding
access to food really difficult and we
all saw those long lines and the
casinos turning into pop-up food
pantries so the need is still there yeah
the need is still there so
we are just thrilled to have the
restaurants participating bringing the
community out to do something
great to help them get back out dine out
enjoy your friends and family all at the
same time doing something to help people
who need help with food and just about
how many restaurants are participating
in restaurant week
we have 120 restaurants over 120
restaurants that are participating this
year
and about 25 of those restaurants that
are extending for the
extra week awesome thank you so much so
one of those restaurants extending the
menu is main street provisions here in
the arts district
a fairly new restaurant open back in
december is that right
yes early december we opened up this is
chef justin here at main street
provisions all right so we've been
sampling
what's on the menu for restaurant week
right now for restaurant week we started
everybody off with our ernie's bird
salad
so kind of a chopped salad based on my
grandfather growing up
and then they have a choice between a
rabbit sausage
which we do a lot of different game
meats here as well or our wagyu steak
with funeral potato
and then we finish it off with bass
cheesecake but
we're going to switch it up a little bit
with the coming week since people have
had a chance to come in and try
everything
we want to give them a chance to try
something new are you still building
that menu or do you have an idea of
what you're going to cook up i'm very
much of a last minute kind of person so
i'll figure it out the next day or two
can i try this yeah
so what is this so this is our best
cheesecake so it's a crustless
cheesecake
we do at a high temp so it's meant to
get a bit of that char
and crack and then we top it with desert
honey a little bit of
orange zest as well oh wow never too
early to have sweets right
not not at all
[Music]
speechless all right well we'll be
posting all the information a great way
to sample what restaurants have to offer
here in the valley
uh we'll be posting all the details on
eightnewsnow.com for now reporting live
hector mejia
back to you john thank you very much a
great cause a great restaurant of course
three square in main street provisions
but we might have to work on the
sampling of food on live television
technique
that is so true hector appreciate that
that cheesecake looked amazing